In the best-selling books,
"The Better Angels of our
Nature" and "Enlightenment Now,"
Harvard linguist Steven Pinker made
the surprisingly controversial
case that humanity
has been getting richer and less violent
over the past two centuries.
In "Rationality: What It Is
Why It Seems Scarce and Why It Matters,"
he argues that our ability to
reason and think critically
is central to human flourishing
and undergirds our phenomenal
material and moral progress
since the enlightenment.
Pinker explains how
important cognitive defects
such as the sunk-cost
fallacy and myside bias
cloud our thinking and contribute
to intensely polarized
tribalistic worldviews
that result in the Trumpian
rights embrace of Q Anon
and what he calls
universities' suffocating
left-wing monoculture.
Not afraid to shy away from controversy,
he insists that public policy
should be largely driven
by facts, not emotion, even
in heart-wrenching cases,
such as the police
killing of George Floyd.
If the goal is to save the
largest number of black lives
or anyone's lives who
are killed by police,
then basing it on a viral video
is probably not the way to go.
Reason talked with
Pinker about rationality,
social progress, and why
despite so much negativity,
fear, and anger in the world,
he's optimistic about the future.
Steven Pinker, thanks
for talking to Reason.
Thanks Nick.
So let's start.
What's elevator pitch for "Rationality:
What It Is Why It Seems
Scarce and Why It Matters?"
Rationality is an introduction to
some of the major tools of reasoning
that don't necessarily
come naturally to us.
Logic, probability theory,
Bayesian reasoning,
correlation and causation,
rational choice theory,
game theory.
It's a exploration of
whether and to what extent
your typical human is rational, that is,
how well do we measure up
against these benchmarks
of reasoning.
It's a explanation as to
why there seems to be such
a rampant insanity in the world.
Belief in paranormal
phenomena, medical quackery,
conspiracy theories.
At one point, you refer to it
as a pandemic of poppycock.
Yes.
Pandemic of poppycock.
And then I think on the
somewhat paradoxical task
of making the case for reason.
Paradoxical, because unless
you've already endorsed reason
as the way that we should believe things,
then there are no tools
with which to defend reason.
But I do my best.
- All right. Let's start with that.
Early on you define reason
or rationality rather
as the use of knowledge to attain goals.
And you talk about a tribe in Africa
that people I think, and certainly,
you know, maybe 50 years ago,
or a hundred years ago would say,
"Well, these people are
primitive. They're not rational."
But you kind of show how
they employ rationality.
Could you talk a little bit about that
and kind of fill in the
definition of rationality
that you're using?
Yeah, I wanted to push back
against the common trope
often appealing to
evolutionary psychology.
A field that I'm quite sympathetic to.
That, well, what do you expect if he wins?
Of course, we're irrational.
We descended from a
caveman on the savannah
who just chucks spears at animals.
And had to run up a
tree if they saw a lion.
We're just nothing but a
bundle of quick reflexes.
But if you actually look
at the lifestyle of people,
the peoples who survive in
a hunter-gatherer existence
in the Kalahari desert.
The case of the San who I
featured in the first chapter,
they are highly cerebral.
They've got to, they survived
by persistence hunting,
which is a uniquely human specialty.
It takes advantage of the
fact that we are naked.
We have no fur, we sweat.
So one thing that we can do in the desert
that other animals can't is run marathons.
We dump heat.
We don't get heat stroke.
Furry animals do, they're faster than us,
but if you pursue them long enough,
they will keel over.
So the trick though is tracking
them because they're fast.
They see a human, they're out of sight,
but they leave behind tracks.
And the San reason from
the tracks to what species
of animal was, what its sex is,
what its condition is,
where it's likely to be.
And they do it even though
lots of tracks look alike,
the tracks get eroded by wind and rain,
and they engage in argumentation.
They doubt their first instincts.
They don't go with their gut.
A young upstart can challenge an elder.
So they don't fall for the
fallacy of argument by authority.
They distinguish
correlation from causation.
They teach Bayesian reasoning.
They use a lot of the tricks of reasoning,
which means that we can't just
excuse our own irrationality.